[Music]
bigquery is Google's serverless highly
scalable and cost effective multi-cloud
data warehouse
it's designed for business agility and
is the heart of our Limitless data cloud
I'm going to provide you with an
overview of bigquery and discuss the
latest developments and give you a sneak
peek into our feature roadmap
my name is Brian Welker I'm a director
of product management of the bigquery
team at Google
I'll be joined in a bit by Jaime tatus
vice president of data strategy and
enables enablement at Telus
I may and I will discuss their digital
transformation and how they are
leveraging the power of bigquery
the promise of data analytics and
artificial intelligence is undeniable
you can see organizational leaders
understand that there's tremendous
potential in harnessing the power of big
data and machine learning to create
compelling customer experiences
optimize operations and get ahead in the
marketplace
there is however a tremendous amount of
difficulty involved in the process of
becoming data-driven and AI powered
in fact a study from a few years ago
found that only 20 percent of analytic
insights actually delivered business
outcomes
another study found that only 10 percent
of companies actually retrieve Financial
benefits from AI
at Google we're very familiar with the
challenge of creating value from data
for example Google search provides
billions of people blazingly fast highly
personalized answers at Limitless scale
and using the same big data and AI
technology that sits behind the world's
biggest websites we've built a data
Cloud that helps you drive Limitless
innovation in your organization
with a focus on being open
integrated and intelligent
bigquery is at the heart of Google's
data cloud
it's a cloud data warehouse designed to
meet the needs of all customers from
those who are just getting started all
the way up to the biggest Enterprises
you might know that bigquery was the
industry's first fully managed
serverless cloud data warehouse and
we've continued to add new capabilities
since the launch of bigquery back in
2010.
bigquery was also the first cloud data
warehouse to offer complete separation
of compute and storage giving customers
flexibility and scaling
bigquery offers broad SQL compatibility
to make it easy for you to migrate to
bigquery
Advanced security features like
fine-grained access controls and
customer managed encryption keys are
built into bigquery at no extra charge
finally bigquery offers industry-leading
High availability and durability
we've seen accelerated growth of
bigquery over the last few years
customers will continue to grow their
data footprint in bigquery a few years
ago it was hard to find a customer with
a petabyte scale data warehouse and now
we have hundreds of customers with over
a petabyte of storage in bigquery
in addition to storage the amount of
query processing continues to Skyrocket
on average bigquery is processing over
110 terabytes of customer data every
second
we're also seeing increased adoption of
bi engine bigquery is low latency
in-memory analysis services with over 3
billion queries accelerated every month
the scale that bigquery operates at is
truly amazing
as amazing as bigquery is it's only one
part of the solution
so we're investing in our partner
ecosystem
we now have over 800 technology Partners
including companies like Quantum metric
shape security and tracks and hundreds
of Technology Partners like stream
mongodp and DBT Labs who've integrated
their Solutions with bigquery
here you can see a quote from Henry
shuck the CEO of Zoom info who are
leveraging bigquery to provide their
customers seamless access to business
data and intelligence
I wanted to Spotlight a few of our
bigquery customers
the first is Carrefour a leading Global
retailer with over 12 000 stores in over
30 countries
car 4 uses a data Lake built on bigquery
to help data scientists Focus their time
on model development instead of data
management
bigquery not only enables Advanced usage
like data science but also allows
traditional data analysts to gain
insights with the SQL tools that they're
familiar with
the second customer I want to Spotlight
is ATB Financial
they serve over eight hundred thousand
customers through hundreds of Bank
branches as well as digital banking
options
in addition to migrating its extensive
sap backbone to Google Cloud ATV chose
bigquery for their data analytics
platform
Google cloud and bigquery has helped ATB
save millions of dollars compared to its
on-premises environment and also
realized millions of dollars in new
business opportunities
finally Telus is a large Canadian
telecommunications company and they're
using bigquery to overhaul their
approach to managing and sharing
information
to provide Insight on this
transformation I'm pleased to welcome
Jaime tatus vice president of data
strategy and enablement at Telus
welcome Jaime
thank you Brian thanks for having me
great now I know that Telus is a
household name in Canada but people in
other countries might not be as familiar
with the company can you give me a quick
overview of Telus and describe your
vision for data analytics of course uh
tell us it's a dynamic we're leading
Communications technology Powerhouse
with over 17 million customers
connections planning from wireless data
IP voice television entertainment video
security Healthcare and agriculture
we're driven by our social purpose and
will leverage globally anything globally
to enable remarkable human outcomes
while supporting Canadians with Superior
technology and a global leading Network
that keep us connected to the people
resources and information that make our
lives better we're accelerating our
digital transformation but working
closely with Google for a 10-year
strategic partnership to advance our
adoption of gcp modernize our core I.T
and network infrastructure and migrate
our on-premise IP infrastructure to the
cloud for enhance scalability and
security while also achieving greater
operational agility
for this partnership we're exploring to
Innovation projects together with the
goal to redefine how Services deliver
globally our vision is to enable Telos
to be a software driven and
cloud-enabled organization that is
Building Technology platforms that can
Power Solutions for our customers and
Enterprises globally
I understand you have some of the
largest data sets in the world but like
many other companies we're limited by
data silos and the high cost of data
management and governance tell us a
little bit about your journey to
overcome these challenges
yeah well Brian as a company that has
been operating for over 30 years with
increasing verticals and growing
Acquisitions we needed a special focus
on executing a data strategy that
leverages the best of technology that
efficiently uses data and analytics and
AI as a main differentiator fueling our
customer experience leadership and
products at superiority
to become data-driven companies cannot
make holistic decisions within data
silos and with our proper agile and
explainable platforms for bringing data
from across our organization curating it
transforming it and reaching it in order
to derive more actionable intelligence
and we leverage bigquery for this
endeavor
as part of our data-driven initiatives
we're consolidating both Legacy and
modern warehouses into single Enterprise
that are Hub in bigquery for the curated
information and insights are available
uh for the company under a privacy and
security by Design construct effectively
democratizing the data scale allowing
business units to Leverage The Power of
our data as part of our migration to gcp
our team is not conducting a lift and
chief of the main corporate warehouses
by running a modernization exercise
where all the data pipelines are
revealed with the latest Enterprise
standards on their SRE principles
bringing higher reliability and better
performance as part of this
modernization effort our team work
across the organization to ensure we
strategically migrate only the data that
is for high quality relevant and
generates value for our business
partners as a result we're not moving
around 20 of the data but deleting it
because it's either obsolete or a
duplicate or not high quality or value
currently we have over four paid advice
of data in bigquery with thousands of
active users in the system
all right my last question is what's
your next big goal in the data analytics
space and are there any upcoming
bigquery features that you're excited
about taking advantage of
thanks Brian well our goal is to
continue in our journey and delivery
capabilities that unlock opportunities
to elevate customer experience and our
unique set of products and services
um as we continue in our path of being a
leading software driven
organization that builds technology
platforms that can Power Solutions for
our customers and Enterprise below
globally
um as relates to bigquery Futures that
are outcoming I will pick the enhanced
data masking that enable varying levels
of access to sensitive data based on
user role it's an exciting combination
of enhanced security and prior and
privacy that deals better processes and
employee user experiences
well Jaime I want to say congratulations
on your successes I'm looking forward to
partnering with you on future projects
thank you so much Brian have a good day
earlier this year we introduced bigquery
migration service it's a comprehensive
solution that enables fast and low-risk
migrations from existing environments
migration service provides tooling for
customers and partners through
assessment translation data transfer and
data validation
we started with teradata and redshift
and through our acquisition last year of
compiler works we recently added support
for 12 more sources including Oracle
ateza vertica and snowflake
one of the hardest pieces of a migration
is modernizing Legacy business logic
like SQL queries scripts and stored
procedures
bigquery migration service provides fast
semantically correct and human readable
translations of Legacy code with no
runtime dependencies translations can be
run in batch mode or ad hoc directly
from the SQL workspace
you might remember a few years ago when
Google acquired a small company called
dataform
data form had built a service for
creating scalable data transformation
pipelines in bigquery we spend some time
integrating it into Google cloud and now
are excited to announce that dataform is
available in preview
dataform provides a SQL based language
called SQL X to Define and manage data
pipelines for preparing and transforming
data for bi and Analytics
you can also prepare data for machine
learning or even for Downstream systems
dataform supports team collaboration and
development best practices by treating
your pipelines as code and managing
versions in GitHub or gitlab
there's no charge for data form outside
of the query execution and storage costs
in bigquery
a few years ago we launched connected
sheets which lets you analyze and
visualize and share bigquery data from
within Google Sheets
connected sheets creates and runs
queries on your behalf either on demand
or on a defined schedule and the results
of those queries are saving your
spreadsheet for analysis and sharing
you can start your analyzes inside of
sheets or write a query in the SQL
editor in the Google Cloud console and
bring it into sheets for further
analysis
previously connected sheets was only
available with the Google workspace
Enterprise pricing plan and we're
excited to announce that it's available
to all sheets users including the free
personal plan
if you're using bigquery there's no
reason not to give it a try
the way the customers have asked to use
bigquery has gone beyond traditional
data warehousing use cases and one of
these use cases is log analytics where
you're ingesting data from devices or
applications and bringing it into
bigquery for analysis
to better support these types of
applications we've added three new
capabilities all now generally available
the first is a new native Json data type
that supports shredding of
semi-structured documents into columnar
store format
and this offers a better performance as
well as better storage compression
over using a standard string type
second search indexes provide the
ability to run what we call needle in a
haystack queries on bigquery data these
indexes accelerate the speed that you
can identify the rows that contain
specific text patterns
there's a small stock charge for the
storage of the index but it really makes
an amazing performance difference
finally the bigquery storage write API
enables our high performance ingestion
screaming ingestion engine
now we built this new ingestion service
that can handle millions of operations
per second without degrading query
performance
while these features can be used
independently together they can be
combined to build powerful log analytics
Solutions
one of the common asks we get is help
with troubleshooting query performance
and today bigquery provides details
about query execution through our
information schema tables but this
information can be sometimes hard to
decipher
query inspector now in preview will
provide additional tools to visualize
and debug query performance including a
query execution graph
bigquery breaks your query down into
multiple stages many of which operate in
parallel and the query graph helps you
to understand the flow of data across
these stages to understand where your
bottlenecks are
query inspector also includes a single
place to view and compare query
performance across multiple queries you
can then drill down to take action on
specific queries
in 2018 bigquery was the first cloud
data warehouse to offer integrated
machine learning and bigquery ml lets
you train execute and deploy machine
learning models in bigquery by using
standard SQL queries
with bigquery ML you don't need to deal
with managing ml infrastructure or worry
about data security just like the rest
of bigquery it's fully automated and
serverless
I'm excited to announce the general
availability of bigquery ml integration
into the vertex AI model registry
the model registry is a central
repository where you can manage the life
cycle of your machine learning models
with a few lines of SQL you can register
your bigquery ml models with model
registry to version evaluate or deploy
for online prediction
last year we launched datastream a
serverless and easy to use change data
capture and replication service
by integrating data stream with bigquery
you can now analyze business events in
real time from your operational system
data stream automatically replicates
both schema and data from the logs of
source databases into bigquery
from there you can run transformation
pipelines or use bigquery features like
materialized views
we're excited to launch into preview a
new built-in integration between data
stream and bigquery with this new
integration data stream replicates
directly into bigquery through our high
performance streaming interface and
there's no need for additional services
data stream includes support for Oracle
and MySQL we've recently launched a
preview for postgres including Amazon
Aurora and Google's new alloy DB
postgres compatible database service
while bigquery has focused to date on
structured data like integers and
strings as well as semi-structured data
like Json we realize there's a huge
amount of insights that can be derived
from unstructured data like images video
audio and text
to enable bigquery customers to take
advantage of unstructured data or
introducing the preview of bigquery
object tables
object tables provide a tabular
representation of the objects in the
Google Cloud Storage bucket you get full
SQL based access to all the object
metadata and can use these tables to
leverage powerful built-in machine
learning models
for example you could use bigquery ml to
predict the likelihood of a rental house
being rented not only based on its
location on the number of bedrooms but
the actual photos of the house
in addition object tables allow you to
create fine-grained access policies to
secure the object data just like you
would in the other table in bigquery
as you can see we have lots of new and
exciting Innovations coming in bigquery
I want to thank Jaime from Telus for
joining me to talk about their journey I
encourage you to start your journey by
exploring bigquery capabilities through
the bigquery sandbox or our free usage
tool tier thanks for watching
[Music]